both those lead and we are learning just
now of a new Israeli attack on a
hospital in Gaza this time on the
Indonesian Hospital in the Gaza Strip
let's
[Laughter]
listen
and
okay um just moments ago we learned of
new Israeli attacks near the Indonesian
Hospital in the Gaza Strip so this
happened a very short while ago um
information is still information is
still coming into us here at aljazera uh
we can uh we're going to be able to
cross live to TK Abu aom who's in the
southern part of the Gaza Strip in just
a moment now remember what we've been
saying over the last few days that
hospitals have repeatedly come under
attack whether it's a hospital directly
or around the hospital and they've
sustained uh damage as a result of
attacks that have happened around them
and those are the pictures that we
appear to be seeing right now remember
also for context that nearly half of
gaza's hospitals are now out of order
the other half obviously vitally
important since uh more than with more
than 9,000 Palestinians killed and many
thousands who have been injured there is
a greater need than ever for medical
facilities in Gaza uh I can now turn to
Tark abazo in Han yunes Tark what do you
know about this latest attack on the
indes
Hospital yes uh the Israeli repeated
attacks against the V the vicinity of
hospitals in Gaza Strip continued since
the early beginning of this round of
fighting different hospitals have become
out of services due to the Israeli
ongoing rates uh during last hour the
Israeli uh Relentless attacks continued
in the north of the Gaza Strip This Time
in the in the surrounding areas of the
Indonesian hospital it's worth
mentioning that this area has been
bombarded several times since the early
the beginning of this fighting now it's
it's also essential to illustrate that
the Indonesian hospital is the only
vital Hospital in the north of the Gaza
Strip which provides uh treatments and
even medical um services for thousands
of Palestinians who are residing in the
north of the Gaza Strip now this
hospital is overwhelmed with residents
who were evacuated and displaced from
the houses in the north of the territory
now uh the uh ongoing Israeli raids in
the surrounding areas aimed to uh
intermidate residents in order to
evacuates within Southern areas of the
Gaza Strip but mwh every single Corner
in the territory has been bombarded and
even with the running low and with the
run out of fuel people cannot really
afford fuel to operate the vehicles in
order to uh hit South to the southern
areas of Gaza Strip as the Israeli
Relentless attacks also keep bombarding
every single vehicle that uh try to
cross and to pass uh through uh from the
Northern areas to the southern areas of
Gaza
the the Indonesian hospital is one that
was still running um t What can you tell
us about first of all what do you
know about the damage that was just done
to this hospital what do you know about
casualties and injuries and I understand
this is at a very early stage so if you
don't have that information we're not
speculating obviously we're just trying
to get as much information as we can
about that
attack yes uh the attacks are in the
surrounding areas of uh the Indonesian
Hospital led to partial damage of some
Departments of the hospitals as uh some
main departments have become really uh
this partially uh damaged and Afflicted
from the Israeli Relentless attacks uh
also it's worth mentioning that the
majority of attacks in the north of the
Gaza Strip and the majority of injured
people are receiving treatment in the uh
Indonesian hospital so uh the massacre
that the massacres that took place in
jabalia refugee camp and the the number
of uh of people who have been killed
have been transferred uh to the
Indonesian hospitals and even the
wounded people are receiving uh
treatment by Medical Teams there
meanwhile this hospital is running glow
on fuel and they are depending now on
miner generators they are operating only
the main departments inside this
Hospital which seems that there is going
to be much more pressure on the medical
teams in order to keep providing medical
services for the on for the ongoing
victims and wounded people who fall from
time to another due to the Israeli
attacks tar tell us about attacks on the
other hospitals today because those
include an attack on the largest
hospital in the Gaza Strip Al shifa
Hospital yes obviously uh the hospitals
in the Gaza Strip are becoming a clear
Target for the Israeli occupation forces
uh it must be protected by the
principles of international law but
meanwhile Medical Teams ambulance
Vehicles drivers and every single
medical worker is considered to be a
legal Target for the Israel occupation
as dozens of ambulance vehicles have
been completely destroyed uh by the
occupation a rid uh the just before a
couple of hours the uh gate of the
Indonesian of the asifa hospital has
been bombarded by the occupation Air
Forces uh an ambulance uh ambulance
Vehicles were preparing to carry victims
and to carry injured people to the
southern areas of the Gaza Strip to be
delivered throughout TR Crossing boarded
the Egyptian S as the Palestinian
Ministry of Health stated they were
bombarded as they were leaving the gates
of the asifa hospital now it's worth
mentioning that the surrounding areas
OFA hospital is very crowded and flooded
with people it's much more larger than
the number of people that are now right
now in the nass Hospital uh it's and
this number and this number of people
also uh is is making the the death to
getting much more stch and much more
increase in terms of the number of
victims fall dozens of Palestinians have
been killed due to this attack uh dozens
of ambulance Vehicles were uh completely
uh and partially destroyed by this air
strike so uh those injured people uh
have been uh according to the
Palestinian Ministry of Health are
supposed to be delivered to rafing in
order to receive treatment there as the
Israeli attacks also uh destroyed and
even killed them and TK you know we
heard from the director of alifa
Hospital a little earlier about 20
minutes ago Muhammad Abu he was
explaining that they have the largest
number of baby incubators they have the
largest intens Care Unit yet their morg
is full of dead bodies and another
element of context this was not the
director saying this but the the we've
heard from your reporting and also yumna
who's in Gaza City that the what little
Medical Aid has reached the Gaza Strip
in the last few days most of it is not
going to the north so it just all of
this Paints the bleakest of pictures for
those hospitals that are still running
in the Gaza Strip especially those in
the
north yes uh to be uh clear uh the
situation on a in a shifa hospital is
really critical it had reached
unprecedented levels uh that could not
be compared with the previous round of
fightings that have been erupted between
Palestinian Fighters and the Israeli
occupation forces uh dead bodies are in
every single corner of the ashifa
hospital the morges the morges have
become full of uh victims and now uh ice
cream trucks have been turned to be as a
a safe place in order to store dead
bodies till the next morning to be later
Pur uh it's also important to mention
that limited number of medical uh
convoys and Med medical AIDS have been
delivered to AA Hospital meanwhile there
is no much kind of medical AIDS
delivered to the north of the Gaza Strip
the main concentration was in the
southern areas of the Gaza Strip
including a nasar hospital and other
hospitals in Rafa District as well so uh
the the Medical Teams there are trying
to operate and to conduct different
kinds of uh surgeries and even uh
amputation proc without using any kind
of BS and sometimes they are forced to
do that on the floor and as they are
really running low in terms of medical
supplies and even the the the quality
and the quantity of medical supplies
that have been delivered to a shifa
hospital is still limited and cannot
really match the uh the needs of the
shifa hospital due to the surging number
of uh wounded people as well so the main
concentration right now is that the
shifa hospital is running loan medical
supplies and they are consuming the
already existing medical supplies that
were afforded before the eruption of
this route of fighting T we talked about
the Indonesian hospital we talked about
alifa Hospital those two hospitals are
in the north and Israel continues to say
the Israeli military continues to tell
gazin who live in the north of the strip
to move down to the South as they've
been saying for quite a while now but
equally what we've seen is that it
hasn't been safe for many of the
Palestinians who have tried to heed that
warning and tried to move South because
there have been attacks whether it's the
attacks on the um on the coastal Road uh
the alrashed road which is one of the
main north to south axes in Gaza or that
medical Convoy that was leaving alifa so
the the question I I'm asking you is at
the moment and this is something you and
I have talked about before as the moment
how do Palestinians know where and when
it is saf fist not safe but saf fist for
them to leave the North and go towards
the south of the
strip well uh the movement between uh
districts in the territory is really
hard by the way and so dangerous in
terms of the uh level of safety that can
be afforded uh now the people in the
Northern areas of the Gaza trip now they
have been trapped in that area they are
not no longer be able to leave the
northern and Central areas of the
territory due to the Israeli military
expansion of their military operations
on the ground and to let you know more
about that these details in terms of the
process of movement from the Northern
areas to the southern areas of the Gaza
STP now we have two main important roads
in the territory AR Rashid road and
salahadin road the AR Rashid Road
considered to be the coastal Road and
salahadin is one of the main Central
longest streets that connect the
Northern areas with the southern areas
of the territory now uh the both uh
streets have been have been controlled
by the Israeli uh occupation ground
troops who are stationed in different
sides of that street of both streets and
specifically in Rashid Street as we
clearly see earlier this morning the
seen and the photage the the the videos
of the dead body that were laying in
every single corner of the Rashida
street that the Israeli military tanks
are hiding behind buildings and even the
naval Israeli forces are launching
different missiles uh to every single
Target or every single vehicle that is
moving from the Northern areas to the
southern areas of the territory so it
will be hard for people to uh feel safe
in terms of the process of of delivery
from the northern areas to the southern
areas and also meanwhile uh the the the
people that are running low on fuel you
are talking about more than 3 weeks of
uh fighting between Palestinian Fighters
and the Israeli occupation forces so
they don't have even if fuel to operate
their vehicles in order to H get an
access to leave as the Israeli also
Relentless attacks continue so the
conditions there is beyond compare they
are really suffering and they have
reached unprecedented deterioration in
terms of humanitarian conditions there t
Kaboom uh thank thank you very much for
your reporting it is just after 1600 GMT
so uh 600 p.m. local